- Good morning, Believe Nation.
My name is Evan Carmichael,
my one word is believe, and
I believe that entrepreneurs
are going to solve all of
the world's major problems.
So to help you on your
journey, today's message is
Find Balance in Your Life.
Over to you, Jet Li.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
(gloomy music)
(cars honking)
- I think balance is really important,
but I think it looks different
for different people.
I think you need to understand
what is balance for you.
As an example, I remember
listening to an audio series
by Tony Robbins, and I love Tony Robbins,
and he was going through,
"Write down your list of goals,
"and talk about, if you want
to be a painter, write down,
"I want to make this painting," or
"I want to write this masterpiece."
"I want to create this poem," or
"I want to make this sculpture,"
and because he was so
excited and into it, like,
"Yeah, I want to make a painting,"
"I want to make a masterpiece."
"I want to create a sculpture,"
and it started building
up my list of things that
I want to do, kind of outside
of just a business world.
And then when I looked at it, I realized,
I don't actually really
want to do those things,
and I got kind of
externally motivated by Tony
in that moment, but it's not really
what balance means to me.
And so I think it's super important,
not to just look at somebody else's life,
but to do a regular audit.
I think one of the most
important things that you can do
as a human being, is do a
quarterly audit of your life,
and see where are you spending your time,
and does it match to the goals
that you're trying to accomplish.
So if you're feeling like
you're working too hard,
then what are the other
activities that you're doing?
How much time are you spending?
And doing that quarterly audit,
because your life will always change,
and your goals and your
priorities will change.
My schedule changes at least once a month,
but in a major way,
probably once a quarter,
where I need to adjust
my priorities based on
how I'm evolving as a human being.
Some things I just don't
care about anymore,
and I'm still spending time on.
So I need to eliminate those.
Some things I need to
spend more time on that
I'm drawn towards, and so
I need to factor that in
and put it in my calendar.
I can tell what your priorities are
by looking at your calendar.
So if there's something that
you think is really important,
if you're trying to find more balance,
if you're trying to work harder,
you want to make sure that
these priorities get done,
schedule it into your calendar,
both the personal things
and the business things, and stick to it.
If you do that, then you'll
be able to build the life
that you want to lead.
So the question of the day today is,
I'm curious, what does
balance look like for you?
Leave it down in the comments below,
super curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Deej Martinez.
Deej, thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book, Your One Word.
It really really really means a lot to me,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, and I'll see
you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- It's complex, right?
And it's deceiving at times.
You know, because people
think the two equate.
- [Interviewer] Yes.
- You know, to each other, and they don't.
- [Interviewer] You have a lot of money.
- It's up, yeah.
And I have a lot of
happiness, but that doesn't
mean that the two equate to each other.
- Has your happiness risen
at the same amount as your bank account?
- No, that's the thing, they don't.
- [Interviewer] They don't
equate, or they're not
tied in any way, or.
- They're not tied to each other.
I mean, it allows you freedom,
and it allows you to go
places where you can smile,
and look at the sunset
and things like that.
That's what you choose to
do, and you enjoy to do.
But there are a lot of
people with tons of money
who aren't happy because either they
become a prisoner of their money,
or they become so consumed
with getting money
that they don't allow time for happiness.
Life is about balance, right?
You have to have some type of balance.
You have, like, time for work,
and there's time for play.
And if you don't allow
these two things to coexist,
you have an imbalance of one or the other.
- I got great advice from
one of the people that
totally fascinates me is
Bob Iger, he's the CEO of
the Walt Disney, ABC world.
So his job is so weird to me,
because he is in charge of everything from
a Disney cruise, to George
Stephanopoulos ABC news.
To like, a theme park, to Scandal.
All of that falls into
the ABC/Disney family.
And I asked him, and it
was very helpful to me,
I asked him a few months ago, like,
"How do you decide what you're
going to work on in a day?"
And he said something so valuable to me,
so I want to share it with you guys.
He said, 80% of his time,
he tries to think about,
"Where can I have impact?
"Where am I going to make a
difference in the day today?"
So it may not usually be Disney cruises,
but sometimes it needs to be,
because the cruise business has been doing
what the cruise business is doing.
That's not quoting him, by the way.
(laughing)
Sometimes it's a Broadway
show that's about to open,
sometimes it's the ESPYS, because ESPN,
that's where his focus needs to be.
So it's really about like,
"Where can I have impact today?"
"Where am I needed?"
And the other 20% is,
"What brings me joy?"
So there are certain movie projects that
fall under the ABC/Disney
world, that bring him joy.
Or certain shows, or certain,
an opening of a park.
There are certain things that bring him.
That just fill him up, that fall in
his work responsibilities.
And I just really have
tried to bring that with me
because it's important for us to remember
the joy in what we do.
It's important to be
effective in our workplace,
but it's important to
cultivate the moments that just
bring us joy, because
that's how we'll shine
in our lives as professionals, you know?
- How do you balance so much?
How do you balance having
such a successful career,
and maintaining your social
life, your family, all of that?
- Well, it's a different
kind of enjoying yourself
when you get older.
As a young girl, before I got married,
I owned property, I had cars,
I lived a luxurious life in fabulous,
like, I was a bachelorette.
My dance card was full, I
had boyfriends, I had a life.
But a career is not going
to keep you warm at night,
and money is not the answer to happiness.
You know, you create an
equal balance of everything.
At least that's what I
say, if you ask Wendy.
That's what I say.
And I only know that because
that's what I live by.